The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw@mit.edu.
DENNIS FREEMAN: With that, what
I want to do is think about--
finish up thinking
about modulation.
Last time we thought
about modulation
in a communications context.
That's a very important context.
It's a way of thinking about how
we can use modulation to better
match a signal to the medium.
So we saw in
particular that if we
were trying to
transmit human voice
via electromagnetic
waves, trying to simply
launch an electrical
representation of the voice
into electromagnetic waves,
just doesn't work very well.
And that's because of the
enormous frequency difference.
We would rather have
frequencies on the order
of 2 gigahertz for
efficient transmission
through the atmosphere and
human voices just are not
centered on 2 gigahertz.
We can use modulation
to bridge that gap.
Having done that, we get a
number of other advantages too.
So for example, we
talked last time
about the idea of
broadcast radio, which
was an enormous revolution.
The idea of being able
to instantly communicate
lots of stuff like a
newspaper, but instantaneously,
not with a day or a week
delay, was an enormous deal.
Today what I want
to think about--
I mean the way we motivated
last time-- the way
to do the modulation that
we motivated last time
was the idea of
amplitude modulation.
Amplitude modulation is a
terribly non-linear process.
We multiply two signals.
That's pretty non-linear.
And you could
imagine that if we're
willing to open up
that can of worms
so that we're willing to
do a transformation that
is non-linear, there's
enormous numbers of them.
So you don't have to just
do amplitude modulation.
You could also do--
here are three
classics-- you can
do phase modulation and
frequency modulation as well.
All of those systems work.
Phase modulation, the idea is--
Well, first off,
amplitude modulation.
The idea was you modulate
so-- this is the carrier.
cos omega ct is the carrier.
That's the thing that goes
through the medium well.
Now we want to somehow embed
the message on the carrier.
In AM, we did that
by multiplying.
We take the signal x of
t and we multiply it.
We take the signal
of interest, x of t,
and we multiply it by the
carrier and transmit that.
And we saw that, for reasons
of decoding simplicity,
it was convenient to add
a constant term, which
was essentially sending, not
only the modulated carrier,
but also the carrier alone,
so that you could locally
retrieve both the modulated
message and the carrier.
It simplified the modulation.
But a different
kind of alternative
is, convey the
message in the phase.
Right?
We all love phase, right?
Nod your head yes.
We all love phase.
So what we could do
instead is take the carrier
and add a phase term in
proportion to the message.
That's a different way of
coding the message on a carrier.
Another way to do it is
to code the frequency.
So take the message,
integrate it--
it is kind of a funny
way to talk about FM.
So you could use the
message to modulate
the frequency of
the carrier, which
would be very similar
to using the message
to modulate the phase.
They, in fact, differ
by an integral.
And I'll talk about
that more in a minute.
So the idea then is even though
the first thing they tried--
the first successful way
of making broadcast radio
--was via AM, we should
think about the alternatives
and try to figure out
what are the advantages
and disadvantages of different
kinds of coding schemes.
And also consistent with
the goals of this course,
in thinking about
these alternatives,
we're going to get
a lot of practice
in thinking about
Fourier transforms.
Which is good.
So let's think about what would
be the difference between AM
modulation, where we convey
the message by modulating
the amplitude of the
carrier versus FM,
where we convey the
message by modulating
the instantaneous
frequency of the carrier.
And if we're just looking
at time domain, which is,
after all, probably the first
place anybody should look--
if we just compare those two
schemes in the time domain,
there's some very
big differences.
You can see that when
we amplitude modulate,
the power that is used
to transmit the message
depends on the message.
So there are places where
there is not much power.
There's not much
energy in this signal.
And there are places
where there's lots.
By contrast, down
here you see something
that has constant power.
At least if you integrate over--
say you've got a 2
gigahertz carrier,
then as long as you integrate
over 10 or 20 cycles, which
is a small fraction
of a second, you're
going to get the same
answer, regardless
of where in the message
you do the integral.
So there is obviously
a power difference.
There's no need to transmit
the carrier in order
to decode the FM signal,
unless of course you're
interested in understanding
exactly where DC is.
The interesting
thing about audio
is that we're very
insensitive to DC.
So that's not really very
important for conveying
speech sounds.
But the original
motivation for thinking
about alternative ways of
coding was in fact bandwidth.
So the idea was there's
a limited resource.
Bandwidth is a limited resource.
If person A is using 1 megahertz
plus or minus 5 kilohertz,
which is one of the
broadcast AM frequency bands,
then person B can't
use that band.
You can have only
one transmitter
for each of the radio bands.
That makes bandwidth-- radio
bandwidth --a resource.
Now there's lots of it.
There's lots of frequencies
between a megahertz and 2
gigahertz.
On the other hand, there's
lots of people who want it.
So your local fire
department thinks
they ought to be able
to talk to each other.
Your local police
department thinks
they ought to be able
to talk to each other.
Your local ambulance
service thinks
they ought to be able
to talk to each other.
So there's lots of people
with demands for it.
So the idea of--
the original pursuit
of FM was to try
to think about a scheme that
would use less bandwidth.
If you're thinking about speech,
you need about 3 kilohertz.
3 kilohertz is considered
telephone quality speech.
It's not perfect,
but it's good enough
to get very good speech
intelligibility across it.
So I AM used plus or minus
5 kilohertz bandwidth.
They allocated a band of 10
kilohertz for every station.
The initial idea in FM to--
so take this expression for FM
and think about an
instantaneous frequency omega
i, which is a frequency with
a slightly different value
from the carrier frequency.
It's different because
we're doing FM.
And you can calculate the
instantaneous frequency
as the derivative of phase.
So the derivative of phase gives
you an omega c term out front.
Omega ct is the carrier phase.
And then there's the
part of the phase
that comes from the message.
So the total
instantaneous frequency
is omega c plus the time
derivative of phase.
And since we're
modulating frequency--
since we're modulating with
the frequency, that turns out
to be proportional to x.
So the instantaneous
frequency, like you
would like for frequency
modulation-- the instantaneous
frequency --is a linear
function of the message x.
But it's proportional.
So the reasoning
was make k small.
If the instantaneous deviations
of frequency are small,
say 10 to the minus 6th hertz--
really small.
Well, if you could have
10 to the minus 6th hertz,
you could pack 10 to the
6th stations in a hertz.
Well that's pretty good.
So instead of using 10
kilohertz to send one message,
you could get 10
to the 6th messages
in one hertz of bandwidth.
That was the
original motivation.
That was an idea that was
propagated at Bell Labs, who
were one of the commercial
entities who were seriously
interested in trying to make
money on broadcast radio.
So the idea was maybe we could
use FM to squeeze more signals
in the available bandwidth.
Well that turns out to
be completely wrong.
And that's why studying
Fourier transforms
is such a good example of how
you can use Fourier transforms
to figure things out.
That argument is just
completely wrong,
as two lines of double-0
3 will show you.
So here is our expression
for the FM signal.
You can see that it's
complicated because it's
the cosine of a sum.
But we all know
from trigonometry,
the cos of a plus b is cos
a cos b minus sine a sine b.
So we can get an exact
expression for this part--
we can expand this
exactly as the cosine
a times the cosine of b minus
the sine of a times the sign
of b.
Well that's easy.
Now what would happen
to that expression
if we made k very small?
Well if we make k very small--
if k goes close
to 0 --the cosine
gets arbitrarily close to 1.
Fine, that sounds OK.
This sine of l times something
does not go-- well the fallacy
in the reasoning
was that goes to 0.
It does go to 0, but it
actually goes to 0 slowly.
It actually-- the limit
approaches k times--
so the limit of the sine of
theta, as theta gets small,
is theta.
So the idea wasn't quite right.
It doesn't go
arbitrarily close to 0.
It gets arbitrarily
close to the message.
So that means that
this expression, which
looks horrible up here, is
equivalent to this expression,
which says that the signal
that I'm transmitting
is the carrier.
Just like AM minus sine
omega ct times the message.
But that's just AM.
I took the message times sine.
Uh, it's sine.
It's not cosine, who cares?
That's a difference of
90 degrees of phase.
Who cares?
It's AM.
The fallacy in the
reasoning is that this k
does not-- the sine of
theta, when theta gets small,
does not go to 0.
It goes to theta.
And so the limiting
case for narrowband FM
has precisely the
same bandwidth as AM.
Narrowband FM has the
same bandwidth as AM,
so therefore, this
whole idea that you
could use FM to squeeze more
channels into a given bandwidth
is just completely wrong.
So it was the
initial motivation.
It's just wrong.
In fact, what's good about
FM is the other limit.
Don't worry about narrowband.
Worry about broadband.
The value of FM--
and this was Armstrong again.
The same guy who did the
superheterodyne receiver, which
made AM broadcast
radio possible.
Same guy went on
to think about FM
and he saw that the
value of FM was, in fact,
to use lots of bandwidth.
Why would you do that?
Well, we'll see in a minute.
That the reason you want
to use a lot of bandwidth
is that you generate a robust
signal that can be recovered,
even when noise
gets added to it.
One of the big
problems, especially
with the early versions
of AM broadcast radio,
was that it had a lot of
noise in the background
we called static.
Kind of like tsss, but
a little bit more poppy
and more irritating.
And Armstrong figured
out that there was a way
to reduce that static by
using more bandwidth to make
a more robust signal.
So that's the idea.
And coincidentally, it gives
us an excellent opportunity
to practice our
skills of figuring out
Fourier transforms.
So let's figure out the Fourier
transform of an FM signal.
Right?
That'll be fun.
Remember what the FM
signal looked like?
We saw back here, it's
kind of horrendous looking.
So the goal for the
next five minutes
is to take the Fourier
transform of that.
So let's think
about phase coding.
Phase and frequency coding
are almost the same thing.
All you do is, in one case you
transmit a phase in proportion
to x.
That's phase modulation.
In the case of
frequency modulation,
you transmit a
phase proportionate
to the integral of x, which
is the same as modulating
the instantaneous
frequency by x.
So let's think about phase
modulating by sine omega mt.
This is omega carrier
and omega message.
And I'm putting an m out front.
The modulation depth.
Just so that I can
track what happens,
as I turn up the
amplitude of the signal.
So let's think about, what
does this signal look like?
So we have cos a plus b.
We expand that as cos a
cos b minus sine a sine b.
And let's start by looking
at this first term, which
is modulated something.
The something is the hard part.
So the something is the
cosine of m sine omega mt.
For the particular case, that
the message is the sine omega
mt.
So let's think about that.
So we'll start with the message.
Sine omega mt.
And we'll say that the
modulation depth is 1.
Now we have to take
the cosine of that.
So now we take the
cosine of this signal.
So this signal is going
0- 1- 0 minus 1- 0.
So the cosine of that-- when
the sine is 0, the cosine is 1.
Then the sine is going toward 1.
As the sine goes toward 1,
the cosine starts going down.
Right?
The first part of the cosine
waves, cosine t, as you
increase from 0.
It starts to decay.
Same thing's happening here.
But then by the time
the sine gets up to 1,
the sign starts going down.
So the cosine starts
going back up.
Everybody see what
I'm what I'm implying?
So this waveform
is a sine waveform.
And this is the cosine
of that waveform.
That's what an FM signal is.
As I increase the
modulation depth,
so make the modulation depth
now 2, now the deviation from 1
is bigger.
Right?
Before, the deviation
for 1 was caused when
the sine wave went up to 1.
Now, the biggest
deviation occurs when
the sine wave gets up to 2.
It's bigger.
And then I may make
it bigger and bigger.
OK.
By the time--
The big difference
between 3 and 4--
3 and 4.
Why is a big difference
between 3 and 4?
It's because there's a
number between 3 and 4.
Pi.
By the time you get
to pi, it rolls over.
Everybody see that?
I started out 1, 2, 3, just
less than pi, 4, just bigger
than pie, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10, 20, 50.
Horrendous, right?
But I want you to find the
Fourier transform of that.
Actually, I want you to find
the Fourier transform of that!
But as a subtopic, I'll accept
the Fourier transform of that.
OK.
Look at your neighbor.
Tell me the Fourier
transform of that.
So what's the Fourier
transform of the bottom thing?
OK.
Was a hard question.
Yes!
Yes.
Oh nice!
It was number 4, got it.
[LAUGH] So what should I
notice about this signal?
Except what?
As a sophisticated signal
processor at this point,
after all it's the
penultimate lecture,
you're already sophisticated.
So as a sophisticated
signal processor,
what do you notice immediately
about that waveform?
It just cries out, I feel.
It says?
Periodic.
Exactly.
Even though it's
horrendous, it's periodic.
Why is that interesting?
It has a series.
Precisely.
So all I need to do to
figure out the transform,
is figure out the series.
OK.
So let's do that.
Now let's start.
The same waveform on the top.
m equals 1, just like before.
Now I'm going to take the series
of this periodic waveform.
And I'm going to
represent that down here.
As you see, as I start to
modulate this waveform,
I'm getting two bumps, where
I had one bump of this--
where I had one period of this.
I'm getting two periods here.
So that's the reason my
first non-0 contribution
is k equals 2.
Also notice that if I turn
to m the whole way down to 0,
I would just get dc k equals 1.
So for the small m's, I'm mostly
getting dc and k equals 2.
OK.
Now as I turn up the
amplitude, now I'm
getting something that
doesn't look quite as
much like a sine wave.
And that distortion is
manifest as some k whose 4.
Then I turn it up higher.
Whoops, I hit the button a few
times more than I intended to.
If I go up to m equals 5, now
it's wrapped around like this.
And I can see I've got k equals
0, 2, 4, 6, and a little 8.
Keep going up, up, up, up.
And what you can see is that
as I turn up the amplitude,
I'm getting bigger
and bigger k's.
In fact, there's kind of
a simple relationship.
By the time I got up to m
equals 50, I got about 50 k's.
Roughly speaking.
And that has something to
do with the periodicity
of the cosine being 6.
2 pi.
So the number of
terms I'm getting
is related to how
big that signal is.
I was able to represent
this horrendous signal now
by a series, but I
asked you for-- what
I'm really trying to do is
find the transform of this.
We just found the
series of this,
but I really want to find
the transform of that.
So I'd like to turn
this into a transform.
How do I turn a
series in a transform?
Turn each k into an impulse.
So now I get a
train of impulses.
Each one of them has
weights proportional
to the length of the lines.
Then each impulse gets located
in frequency, instead of
in k space, each impulse
gets located in frequency
at a multiple of
2 pi over omega m.
So when I do that,
I get the transform
of this mass, which looks
like this centered here,
but then I modulate
by the cosine.
So modulation gives
me two copies.
I get the whole spectrum
for the inside here
and a duplicate over there.
This time centered on omega c.
That's all perfectly clear.
Right?
So then I just did this term.
Now I have to worry about that
term, but it's the same thing.
Except now my periodicity
is a little different.
Now I'm taking the
sine of the sine
rather than the cos of the sine.
So now as I crank
up the waveforms,
the picture looks
slightly different.
The principle
harmonics are now odd
because of the odd
symmetry of the sine wave.
I had evens when I used cosine.
I have odds when I use sine.
So now I'm filling in a
bunch of odd harmonics,
but the general pattern
looks very similar.
So that now the result looks
very similar to the result
from before.
And the sum is the sum.
Here's the Fourier transform
of this waveform y of t.
The point is it's
huge bandwidth.
The advantage of FM is not
in conserving bandwidth,
it's actually using bandwidth.
So we're using-- this
is the K, big case.
So we're doing wideband FM.
We're shoving
frequency components
all over the spectrum,
but the advantage of that
is that I get a signal
that's very robust.
Imagine if I were to add a small
level of noise to this signal.
You could still
recover the signal.
The only thing
that's coded here is
one sine wave that
has one period
across that whole length.
You could recover that in
the absence of, not only
a little noise, but an
enormous amount of noise.
And that was what
FM was good for.
And that's what
Armstrong figured out.
And that's why we have FM.
And that's why
television, even HDTV,
uses FM coding of the audio.
Because it's resilient to noise.
So that was kind of a motivation
for thinking about modulation,
in terms of communications.
I don't want you to go away
thinking about modulation
as only useful for
communications,
so I want to close with
a kind of unconventional
use of modulation.
I may have mentioned
that I like microscopy.
I'm going to show you how
you can use modulation
to improve microscopy.
So this was an idea of
Michael Mermelstein.
Michael was a PhD
student in my lab.
He thought of it.
Stan and Jay developed it.
They all three got
PhD's on this topic.
Berthold is a professor
in CS and five of us
worked on this project.
So the idea is improving
microscopy with 6.003.
With modulation in particular.
You've all seen this.
This is the double-0 3
model of a microscope.
Double-0 3 microscope convolved
with blurring function.
Done.
That's what a microscope is.
That's the double-0 3
model of a microscope.
Microscope is a low pass filter.
Because all of the different
spatial frequencies
that are available
in the target can't
get through all the lenses
for very fundamental reasons
in physics, the high
frequencies don't make it.
The low frequencies do.
The result is a blurred image.
So I'm representing
this as the target.
It passes through
the microscope, which
is represented by
a low pass filter
and it comes out
a blurry picture.
Michael's idea was instead
of illuminating the target
with uniform light--
if you tear apart a
microscope, a lot of the guts
are intended to make a
nice uniform light that
goes across the target.
Nice uniform illumination.
Michael's idea was,
let's not do that.
Let's project stripes on it.
That's a little bizarre.
So instead of having a nice,
blurry picture of a target,
Michael wanted me to
generate blurry pictures
of stripey targets.
But you're a sophisticated
double-0 3 people, as well as
Michael.
Why does he want to do that?
Different frequency.
Phase modulated microscopy.
That's why he wants to do this.
We're going to
modulate microscopy.
OK, well what's that?
OK, so Stan Hong was one
of our TA's in double-0 3.
And he wanted to explain
the way this works
using purely double-0 3 terms.
He also knew that I would
be receptive to that
and that Bertold Horn, who
teaches this course all
the time, would be receptive
to that kind of an argument.
So Stan made a picture
to illustrate that.
So here Stan's picture.
What do you see?
Nice picture, right?
Great.
Excellent.
That's exactly right.
Some of you close to the
front, what do you see?
Stripes.
So what you see is stripes.
And if I were sitting
where you're sitting,
I wouldn't see the stripes.
Why is that?
Because my eyes, like any
optical system, blurs.
Me being old, they blur
more than you being young.
You can see stripes
better than I can.
So if I were to sit
there or if I read it--
or if you were to
sit-in the back row it
would be hard to see the stripes
would you still see blur.
You'd still see gray.
So what do I do?
This is double-0 3.
We just did phase
modulated microscopy,
but what should I do next?
I have a stripey picture.
How did that
picture get stripey?
It got modulated.
What should I do next?
Demodulate it.
So how do we do that?
Do the same process when--
and that process was?
So I put stripes--
I illuminated the
picture with stripes
in order to make the original.
Now what I should do is
illuminate the result
with stripes.
If I multiply the
picture by stripes
I'm phase modulating it.
Multiply by cos omega
whatever, right?
So now I'll put
the clicker down.
No cheating, right?
Nothing up my sleeves.
And now I'm going to project
that stripey pattern.
Cute, huh?
It's pretty amazing.
So who is that?
Fourier.
Good.
That's the principle behind
Michael's microscope.
And by the way,
I'm not cheating.
So if I roll the phase--
It works just like radio.
Now how's it work?
And how well-- so
that was a demo.
Stan's committee loved it.
Here's the idea.
So the poster was phase
modulated Fourier.
Fourier is a
function of x and y.
And you modulate the
phase of carrier.
The carrier now is
the y displacement
because we were putting
this kind of line on it.
So we modulated carrier.
Cos omega cy was the carrier
by the phase of Fourier.
So we bumped the
lines up and down.
We being, Stan.
Stan bumped the lines up
and down in proportion
to the brightness of Fourier.
And that put Fourier's
content centered on omega c.
It was hard to see from the
audience because your eyes--
the projector projected omega c.
It's hard for you to
see from the audience
because your visible frequencies
in space don't go that high,
but you beat it with
the stripey pattern,
that modulates in space just
the way it modulates in time.
And it takes a copy
of Fourier, which
had been modulated up
to omega c and bumps it
back down to the visible.
That's why you can see it.
Well, we're going to
see that in a moment.
Good question.
The idea is precisely the same
as the superheterodyne radio.
If this is the
complicated picture
that we would like
to look at-- this
is the Fourier transform
or the complicated picture
that we would like to look at.
If we demodulate with
this stripe at omega c,
we're able to bounce
down this pe house
and we're able to see
that part of the picture,
even though those frequencies
are too high for them
to go through the microscope.
There's a limited number
of frequencies that
will go through the microscope.
Just like there's a limited
number of frequencies
that'll go through your eye.
And we can take a band of
frequencies, that don't make it
through the microscope, beat
it with this stripey pattern
into a frequency range that
does go through the microscope.
Then we can change
the stripey pattern.
If we make stripey pattern
with slightly higher frequency,
we get a different part
of the invisible spectrum.
And we just keep repeating.
There's a bit of an issue
that it's a 2D transform.
We have to worry
about frequencies
in x and frequencies in
y, but we are all experts
at this sort of thing.
The difference between stripes
this way and stripes this way
is Fourier's this way
and Fourier's that way.
You rotate the stripe.
It just rotates the
Fourier transform.
We can think about, in space
we can modulate like that
or we can modulate like that.
And in fact, what
we would like to do
is modulate by a whole
bunch, so that we could
take all these little regions--
so say the circle
corresponds to the radius
of frequencies that get
through the optical microscope.
What we'd like to do is
put that little radius
at every possible
place, one of the time,
to bring down those frequencies
in the target, one at a time.
So the idea--
Then the problem
becomes, how do you
make so many stripey patterns?
And you have to generate
those stripey patterns at very
high spatial frequencies.
Very small distances.
If you're going to
beat a microscope--
Optical microscope
resolutions are
on the order of 500 nanometers.
Wavelength of light.
So you're going to have to make
these patterns small compared
to the wavelength of light.
So Michael's idea
was interference.
You take two coherent
laser beams, point them
toward each other but
at a slight angle,
and they will interfere
and make a stripey pattern.
Then you turn on a
different pair of beams
and you get a different
stripey pattern.
Different.
I'm showing on the left, the
spatial, and on the right,
the Fourier transform.
Fourier transform for
the stripey pattern.
All light-- all pictures
have some dc because there's
no negative photons.
So that's this.
And these are coding--
the angle is coding
the orientation
and the distance is
coding the pitch.
Different stripey pattern.
Different.
There's a bunch of them.
With 15 beams, you get 15k 2.
Order 15 squared.
That's the idea.
And that was Michael.
This is Stan.
Stan figured out a way
to build an apparatus
to take the beam from a
laser, break it into 15 parts,
steer it with a
bunch of mirrors,
and point them all
toward the center.
So the target-- so the
lasers coming in over here.
There's these pick-off mirrors
steering things around.
This was some complicated
optimization that Stan did.
Here is the region
of interest, which
is this big on his microscope.
And about 2 centimeters
down, the beams
converge on a specimen.
Which is right there.
So if we zoom in and you can
see it a little bit better,
there is a conventional
microscope objective
with 15 beams fired toward it.
Now the idea is you put the
specimen between the beams
and the objective.
And then you view the
stripey illuminated target
with the microscope objective.
Here is a picture
taken by Jay, where
he took a bunch of small beads.
It's easy to get plastic beads
of very uniform dimension.
So these are about
1 micron beads
and about a gazillion of them.
So he just made a
solution of beads,
put them on a glass
slide, evaporated it
so that he would have a random
constellation of plastic beads
all one micron in diameter.
And here's one picture of it.
And you can see the pixels.
Each one of these squares
is one pixel in the camera.
I'm zooming in a lot.
Keep in mind that
these guys are only
about a micron in dimension.
But then if you change
the stripey pattern,
you get a slightly
different picture.
And if you change this
stripey pattern again.
And again.
So he recorded then, 300
and some odd pictures
of the same thing with
different stripey patterns.
Then he did some
signal processing
and turned that sequence of
pictures into that picture.
So you can see the
resolution is up a bit.
The resolution is
very sub-pixel.
You can see many
resolution elements
inside one pixel from
the original picture.
In fact, if you
compare the original
to the reconstruction--
so this is one picture taken
with uniform illumination.
This is the result of
calculating some 300 pictures
with structured illumination,
with different structure
in each picture.
And you can see a lot
better resolution here.
In fact, you can
see here there's
something that looks
like it might be a bead,
but over here you can see more
clearly it's really two beads.
And if you take a solitary
bead and plot the brightness
through a line, you get this.
But if you plot the brightness
through a reconstruction,
you get something much narrower.
Stan then developed a method
for scanning this around.
He also developed a method
for measuring the point spread
function directly.
Here I want to show
you a measurement,
same sort of apparatus,
with a 200 nanometer bead.
A much smaller bead.
Keep in mind that the
apparent brightness
goes as the cube of diameter.
So changing the diameter
by a factor of five,
changed the apparent
brightness by 5 cubed.
So here is a picture taken
with Stan's microscope.
And if we take a row of pixels
and plot the brightness,
this is the reconstructed
image by using
standing wave illumination,
which is what we called it.
And it's got an apparent
diameter of 290.
The 290 is bigger than the
200 because of the blurring
of the microscope.
The prediction, based on the
angle of the laser beams--
the resolution of
this microscope
depends on the
angle of the laser
beams because the angle
of the laser beams
determines the
pitch of the fringe.
That the pitch of
the stripey pattern.
So the prediction, based
on the angle of the beams
from the apparatus, was that
it should have been 250.
And the fairest thing
to compare that to
is, what would it have been
if we hadn't used any wave
illumination?
If we hadn't used
any illumination,
it would have been
1500 nanometers.
So you can see, there's
an enormous increase
in the resolution by using this
phase modulated microscopy.
So the point is that you
can use modulation for a lot
other things than
communications.
Because the application
and communications
is terribly important,
but here was
a completely different
application of modulation
to improve microscopy.
Thank you.
See you next time.
Fill out the subject evaluation.